yeah there are some please I just can't
get my head to go so this one's just a
little bit of an explanatory video
actually not all dissimilar from the one
I did I think it was last year
explaining why I'm not I don't really
get into shipping although I think the
reasons are a bit different in this case
in that case it was because shipping
means indulging in the kinds of romantic
entanglements that I would actually
forcibly remove from the vast majority
of entertainment that I per taken in the
first place I'm not gonna pretend to
pair off people when most of the time I
don't want them I don't want anybody
actually pair it off that's not the same
when I do percent above it but anyway
and I'm rehashing stop move forward so
this time I'm gonna talk about fan
theory which every now and then I have
somebody ask either in the comments or
in a live stream you know either what my
thoughts on a fan theory are or do I
have any theories about well usually
doctor who occasionally Star Wars or
Marvel but in general fan Theory just is
not something I'm able to really put a
kin either in terms of doing it myself
or really just even diving into other
people's so this might actually anyone
who's been around for a long time and I
mean a long time on this channel this
might strike you as odd because I think
it was the very first doctor who really
know it wasn't the very first but one of
the first doctor who related videos I
ever did was my own theory and
prediction about the then-upcoming day
of the doctor yeah I've been doing this
for a long dang time and turned out it
was wrong but that was kind of a rare
exception where my brain kind of clicked
of like ooh maybe it's this but also if
you actually go back and watch that
video heck I'll link to it why not you
might notice that my thoughts are pretty
vague I don't have a
detailed theory I don't have this
specific oh well its listen connects to
this and it's backed up by this this
this this is then this it's not I want
to say that it's like half formed but it
is it's the bones of a theory and that's
a big part of why I don't get into this
because most people who really dive into
it what most people are looking for when
they ask for a fan theory is something
really meticulously plotted out and
intricate something like I hate to use
it as an example cuz it's kind of dumb
but something like the Jar Jar Binks is
insist is a Sith Lord fan theory that I
never bought for even a half second and
I did read I'd say about half of the
really detailed version of that but part
of what was intriguing was seeing how
many dots somebody was connecting in
order to back up this idea but my brain
just doesn't work like that for a number
of reasons part of it is because as some
with my own creative ambitions the
amount of honestly inventive creativity
so this is not to knock people who do
fan theory but the amount of creative
investment they have to put into that
part of my brain keeps going why aren't
you working on your own stuff why are
you making up what what somebody else's
universe looks like get back to your own
frigging things so and again that's just
my brain and that's the that's the thing
I don't have a problem with fan theory
although it is hard for me to take in
like I mentioned even that Star Wars one
I really only saw like little bits and
generally whatever I take in fan theory
I tend to enjoy it much more if it's
super detailed and about something I'm
actually not a fan of so like I will
watch things on I mean that I know it's
the mainstream version yeah I'm a pleb
but you know things like film theory and
game theory I will watch but almost
never what is about something I actually
know about but I I will watch game
theory videos on five nights at Freddy's
all day long I enjoy them because I
enjoy the meticulousness of it but I
need a detachment from the fandom
because if I know about it if I know
enough about the thing they're talking
about then there's a different voice
comes up in my head and that voice says
no there's no way that this massive
hidden thing has been part of the plan
from the get-go and that and again
that's not meant to disparage fan theory
I don't at least I don't think someone
can correct me I don't think people who
indulge in a lot of fan theory are
necessarily hung up on exactly trying to
find out what is gone I think maybe some
are but there's certainly an
inventiveness in can I make these bits
that don't make sense can I find a way
to make them fit I think that's also
part of why I find fan theory more a
little easier to digest on something
that's done as opposed to something that
in theory your theory will either be
confirmed or denied from an upcoming
piece of media so like I couldn't get
into any of the fan many fan Theory
videos I saw talking about who's the
timeless child or who are raised parents
gonna end up being or you know anything
like that because I knew well we're
going to get the answer anyway and it's
funny for as much as I have I think
anyways a fair amount of creative energy
and my brain likes to do creative things
I also have a pretty strong pragmatic
sense I have a pretty strong voice in my
brain that says this is a waste of time
and not in that like nobody cares about
your projects way but more na why would
you spend a ton of time coming up with a
theory on something when you could just
wait three months see the movie and find
out what its gonna be anyways and again
not to disparage anyone who does that I
think if you can do that you can indulge
in it and it's fun for you awesome my
brain won't let me do that cuz I can't
shut off that little voice that says
there's no point to something else
so that's that's kind of a big part of
the hang-up for me for just why I have a
hard time getting into it or even taking
in other folks who do because I don't
want to outwit you know the creators of
something I don't need to figure out the
secret that they've been hiding and I
don't also need to connect all the dots
actually there's a fair amount of things
that I like where part of the reason I
like them is because some of the dots
are unconnected so whether or not you
can appreciate fan theory indulge in fan
Theory enjoy it as a form of
entertainment I think it has a bit to do
with either how much you enjoy
connecting dots or seeing them connected
and again for me to enjoy that it needs
to be something I actually have no
commitment in because there's a certain
technical and inventive this to that
that I enjoy and I appreciate but again
if it's anything that I care about it's
it's it's oddly harder because I think
I'm much more likely to just go no no
that doesn't track whereas if I don't
know much about the thing I don't know
if that tracks or not I can just enjoy
this ridiculous thing that I'm watching
getting laid out and that can be fun but
it's not something anyone should ever
expect from this channel or from me to
either produce fan theory or to really
offer them up much commentary and part
of the other reason that I avoid fan
theory particularly on anything coming
up is I did accidentally on at one point
stumble across a fan theory that ended
up being right and therefore ended up
being a spoiler so that's another reason
aside from the ones I already mentioned
that for me I prefer to avoid fan theory
about anything that is ongoing and not
yet finished because I would kind of
like to experience whatever the thing
might be with the amount of knowledge
that I'm expected to have not this extra
knowledge that I should know so that's
that is yet one more deterrent so if
anyone wants to share fan theories with
me I probably be more open to looking at
the ones that sort of connect loose
threads to something that's already done
definitely the predictive ones I'm not a
huge fan of but it's just not something
you'll get on this channel and watch how
much you want to bet that like a week
after this goes up I'm gonna have like a
bolt of inspiration for like a
ridiculous fan theory video because
that's another thing my brain likes to
do make a liar out of me but in any case
we'll wrap it up their fan theory it's
cool it's not really my thing for the
most part anyways just putting that out
there because well I don't know because
I wanted to just put it on the record so
whatever your thoughts on fan theory
favorite fan theories you have fan
theories that you've come up with or
just explain to me why you either enjoy
watching fan theories or reading them or
coming up with them on your own I kind
of appreciate the insight from people
who get more out of it than I do
whatever your thoughts are drop
something on down in the comments let's
talk about it all the usual stuff like
subscribe bail patreon link in the
description you don't have to click on
it though I'd appreciate it for sure but
end of the day you're the council I just
run the meetings and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]